gentlemen I am super happy to talk to
you guys today uh but before we get
started can everyone sort of say on
camera uh your name and what you did on
the short
film uh I'm Bob Odenkirk I wrote the
film wish me luck and I acted as the
lead
character my name is John Aiden I
directed this short film and I helped uh
ucing also training
Bob hi I'm Daniel burnhard I'm the
action director on it I was an actor on
it with Bob I had a pleasure working
with Bob on it I also trained Bob for a
long time for this and um also helped
produce it hey I'm Charlie Yun and um
I'm a stunt man and I helped the movie
to become a better fight fight fight
coordinator I was fight coordinator yeah
with with bong as well yeah like you
said Fong Jang is my name and I was one
of the fight coordinators and yeah we
were also acting in it right like
fighting exactly
Happ I mean I have to say that uh Johan
Aiden did so much to make this movie
directing it and putting this production
together Sean you want I I really want
to give credit to so many people who
helped us um who you know I've not even
met you know um how did you do this I
I'm Stephen you're running the interview
but if you don't mind me saying I I've
gotta say I didn't expect look I was
gonna we knew nobody was going to happen
I'd been training for a long long time
probably a year and a half but I was
very aware that once you put cameras in
front of me once you ask me to redo the
stunt fight again when there are changes
made to the fight for various reasons
that's an experience I hadn't had and I
wanted to have that experience with
lights and a crew and a time limit and
challenges I wanted to to make something
after all this training and and put my
training under the pressure of an actual
film set and John and Daniel are very
close and we saw each other at
8711 uh in LA and John said I will
produce the movie if you write it I I'll
direct it and I'll make it happen if we
can do it in
Berlin so um then I just you know Daniel
and I planned out this fight John and
everybody here helped with
that and we went to Berlin for about
five or six days we prepped a little bit
for two or three days and then we shot
for three days but John how did you put
that production together and get all
those
people uh those are are people that I
has been working for I don't know like
six seven years like that's a team that
I was been working for for a long time
and yeah when you guys approached me and
Daniel was saying like hey would you
like to do it maybe over there in
Germany I said yeah sure let's go for it
let's do it so I called my friends up um
there's a guy called uuk kench and he's
the owner uh of the post- production
company uh cine cine pulse and c
chromatics and uh he also produced Plan
B with me and a few other short films
and he's also a line producer for
various of uh TV shows over there and I
told him like let's put that together
and let's bring the team uh back
together the team that we've been
working for for a while and that's how
we started actually and he said like
when do you want to shoot and I said
like actually in two weeks and he said
okay great as always let's go for it
let's do it and um yeah that's how we
started it yeah if I made just add
something to this it was actually really
funny you know after Bob and I were
training really hard for for nobody and
then Bob came up with the idea to do the
short and you know Chan and I were
really old friends and we worked
together for a long long long time in
the past and we're old buddies we've
done a lot of movies together and I went
to Chan and I said hey John what do you
think and he goes I can do it and first
we wanted to do it here but here it just
didn't make sense it was too hard and
then John put this whole thing together
which was amazing so we're very very
grateful very
grateful well I'm just I'm curious so
just to be clear you went to Berlin was
this did you go to Berlin just to make
the shorter this is where you shot B
like that's where you shot wait I'm so
you just went to Berlin just to shoot
this yeah oh wow I thought it was it was
months before we shot nobody months
before but we knew it was a go project
and I knew I was going to have to step
in front of the camera in a few months
and actually do all that I'd trained for
but I knew two that I I didn't want to
step in front of the cameras for the
first time on nobody which was a very
important opportunity for me I wanted to
take a run at it and this was uh this is
my you know I I we I didn't know it
would turn out so well I'm really proud
of this little movie I love this movie I
even think there's I even think there's
more going on here than you can see as
far as a story of a character and and a
Vibe that's different from
nobody um I'm not sure how much um the
audience or even you Stephen would grasp
the ways I mean you're a pro at this but
to me I it's it's a bigger thing in my
mind than it might seem uh to actually
watch it's only eight minutes long but
there's a lot going on in there that um
is actually a little varied from nobody
I think we do some fighting John Fong
helped me uh develop some moves and some
choices that are more um they're more um
cheeky they're more fun I mean nobody
was kind of a hard
bludgeon you know
um it it was meant to not be cute you
know nobody it was meant to be
heavy and this movie um wish me luck I
wanted the opportunity before I went to
do nobody to try some fighting that was
a little more
uh uh
clever and yeah if I can ask okay so
just just for time for like the timeline
so Bob how long had you been training
for
nobody uh before you shot this and was
it like you were done training for
nobody or you were going to be training
for nobody till you started filming yeah
I had a lot more training to do for
nobody body but I had been trading for
about a year and a half at least so my
the thing about this short film is that
yeah you've been doing all that training
and it's one thing to train in the gym
and try to learn the moves it's another
thing to be standing on in front of you
know cameras with actors having to make
shots and also have this done in two
three days so what what surprised you
when you started getting in front of
cameras in terms of doing an action
scene and working with everyone
the number one thing was how much it was
like a comedy writer's
room which is to say I spent so much of
my career in comedy writing rooms at
Saturday Night Live Mr show Tenacious D
all these other places birthday boys all
these sketch shows and when you're in
that room you've got a bunch of people
mostly guys I'm sorry to
say and they're confronting challenges
coming up with ideas building on each
other's ideas fixing things that don't
quite work and that was the same kind of
problem solving that I found on the in
the course of you know shooting not
planning so much but shooting a um an
action sequence is that no matter how
much you've planned and prepped and
choreographed there are Al alterations
that have to happen or that have an
inspirational purpose like somebody has
an idea that's really fun and
so it it really is a group effort once
you get to set now Daniel and I planned
this fight and Sean helped plan it as
well and then when we got there we did
more planning together but still once
you get on the set people like cha and
Fong they're there to contribute ideas
too and say why don't you try this I'll
move here something doesn't quite work
for the camera angle some some somebody
just has a better idea and it really is
a group effort that ends up with a lot
of
laughter I mean there's a lot of
laughing that goes on and that's another
way it reminded me of a comedy writer
room is like uh you make a change you do
the thing somebody says you know John
says action John says cut and everyone
laughs because it worked and um so the
biggest surprise was the way it was um a
group effort and a a lively effort
something that comes to life um as you
do it so something I want to touch on is
that one of the things that in this
short film you have you're not cutting
every millisecond I have watched some
action recently that has made me so
frustrated because it's like three Cuts
every second and I'm like it makes me
bonkers but the reason why nobody works
why John Wick works why this short film
works is you can see Bob doing stuff and
it's like an actual like you know it's
you're not cutting every millisecond so
can you can you sort of talk about
making like pulling that off and the
importance of not cutting every
millisecond Sean you go ahead take this
you
directed I mean um the foundation was
there the way how Daniel and Bob trained
uh gave us a very good foundation to be
honest and uh Bob allowed us because he
was able to pull off the long takes to
stay longer on him which allowed us to
also see the beauty in the fights and it
was very ecstatically very beautiful for
us and um giving us also the opportunity
to stay as I said longer on long takes
on Bob and see whatever he's doing and
follow his movements gave us the gave us
a lot of room for longer takes and uh
seeing like what we could do uh with the
Coro itself but again great job to
Daniel and the guys I mean they gave
gave us the foundation to do that and
Bob willing to train more than one and a
half years gave us the opportunity to go
again as I said with longer takes but
the thing is Stephen when I went entered
into this I mean there's various reasons
why I brought up the idea of an action
movie to my manager um one being the way
the kind of character I played in Better
Call Saul which played around the world
for people uh an Earnest guy who is
clever a problem solver who is
uh indefatigable never quits um and I
thought he was an action character
without the fighting so all I was adding
to that was fighting and uh um but I but
I asked myself what what can I really
contribute you know I'm not the most
statuesque human whoever lived I'm no
Schwarzenegger and uh but I thought you
know well I'm maybe more of an actor
than some people who Venture into this
area and so in order to bring the acting
to the screen while doing the fighting I
need to the camera needs to stay on me I
I can maybe play a guy who in the middle
of the fight is still in character and
is
still that
specific person that was presented to
the audience that person in the middle
of a fight
what is he feeling is he and in in my
case I like playing a person who's maybe
a little unsure of himself or very
unsure of himself which I think adds to
the stakes of the
fight Daniel I'm curious if someone has
never done action before um Allah bab or
say me for example let's use me as an
example I've never done action before
how long do you think it would take to
train someone who's never done it to
actually look good on screen and is
there like a natural ability that people
have to have to be able to do it or can
anyone like with enough training do you
think they can do action this question
is for me right yeah so I had this
beautiful challenge I got approached by
Dave and Kelly they came up to me and
said Hey listen we're gonna do nobody
you're gonna be in it anyway which you
be interested in training Bob and I love
Bob's work huge fan of his work and I
said absolutely so the funny thing is
I've trained a lot of actors in my in my
time and when I met Bob Bob told me
Daniel I've I've never done this before
I hike and I ride to bike that's all I
do but Bob had a certain gift I mean
he's an amazing actor and I I approach
it from an acting point so once we start
training we have a very specific way how
we train actors it's not what you think
we're not going and punch the punching
bag and hit mids it's not like that it's
all about hit movement but Bob actually
had a very natural talent and was really
really willing to learn and that's the
most important thing it's his energy how
he wanted to learn and sometimes Bob and
I trained twice a day we trained for a
long time then we did like Bob said we
wanted to do the short which was a lot
of fun and we all decided together
because of Bob's comedy background we
wanted to make it more fun we wanted to
do it in a Jackie Chan kind of way and
that's how we did the Coro with the boys
with Chan with Bob we put in a lot of
Comedy there was really funny things
with the tie remember that was amazing a
lot of laughs like Bob was saying we
laughed so
hard but it was really Bob's effort like
Bob's giving me a lot of credit for the
training but it's not me it's him he's
the one you know your patience and I
mean Daniel I I was embarrassed to be at
8711 for the first year that I was there
I mean I would look around and see
people like cha and Fong and training
and John was there training sometimes
and many people come through there and
they're pros and here I am in a corner
with Daniel and I really am not even I
shouldn't be in that gym but you know
what it is Stephen
um I I knew I had to tr I knew I didn't
have a lot to um a gifted natural
ability that I could
bring uh to this genre which I respect
you know I respect all the people who've
spent their whole lives making genre
action films they love these movies you
love these movies you love sci-fi films
you know I don't go well let me do it I
it'll be easy I recognize that there's
years of effort and thought and choices
that go into every one of these movies
and and
so I it was very hard Daniel I mean it
was embarrassing to be in that room and
I
can I add one thing Bob what you don't
know while you were there even after two
three weeks people came up to me all my
friends the ones you just mentioned
everybody came up to me saying oh my God
look at Bob look how well he's doing and
what's really important in our world for
Chan me thong and Cha what's really
important sometimes it's not just about
the move it's about your acting and the
great thing what Bob did there's a
secret what we were saying earlier about
the quick editing when somebody no good
there's a lot of quick editing the
better somebody is the longer you like
Chan was saying the long you hold the
shot so with Bob what we did is in the
beginning we said Hey listen if Bob is
not that great in it we'll go super
tight but the better you are the wider
we can go now look what we did with Bob
medium shots full length shots sometimes
a closeup of the reaction and that's to
you Bob because you did so great well we
put our time in you know what it is
Stephen after about literally I think it
was a year maybe a little more that was
when Daniel said finally you know slow
down your moves a little bit um but it
took me a year plus to get to the point
where he was like okay now you know
don't move quite as fast there's still a
lot there's a lot more than just speed
at work at work work here but it was a
great moment to feel that I had at least
gotten to a place where I could I could
actually consciously maybe slow down my
moves a little so they show up well on
camera and of course uh well there's a
lot more to it than that and I'm still
training well I mean I I'm going to be
honest I really hope you're still
training because I'd like to see a
sequel to a certain
nobody well look we're
all everyone's trying to make that
happen Stephen uh we really are um I
want to get a I want to make a sequel to
wish me luck I can tell you that right
now listen the thing about the short is
that um it's eight minutes but you are
obviously setting up in the short
because you can you know I don't want to
say specifically so people can watch it
but you know there's stuff going on
whether it be the ending whether it be
how the character got there there
there's a million things and and it's
just a question of what you guys want to
actually do and who gives you the money
to make you know what I'll tell you what
Stephen
there I love Jackie Chan and I love the
early jackiechan films
and so in this movie and wish me luck
you'll see some of my moves are more
cute or clever sillier funnier the moves
are funny the choices are fun and
there's no blood and I think because I
come from Comedy I think there's a
version of an action movie that I could
do that's more like wish me luck that
has a cheekiness to it and a a a more of
a cleverness of within the
fighting what what gets made first
nobody to or the wish me luck
feature good question tricky question
probably nobody too is
my but you know who knows who knows I'm
just gonna I'm
just I'm gonna drill down Bob have you
been writing a wish me luck feature
script I have I have and I'm also
thinking about a series because uh I
like some of the work that's been done
on Jack Reacher and
uh films you know stuff like that I
think there's a lightness you can do in
that world that's
um that is totally acceptable there and
I think there's something funny about um
well I don't want to get you in and I
have worked together so much over the
last three years and I feel like it
there's a fun story in me and him as a
two-hander type show that's my dream and
uh he's certainly done his work you've
you've all you've seen him you know
Stephen how much Daniel's done and that
goes for Chan Fong and Chan to but
Daniel's been in every goddamn thing and
and he's developed as an actor and he's
a very fun likable guy I think there's a
there's a story in here where we both
get to uh do the story play it out so I
a relationship that could be really fun
on camera so uh I'm thinking about you
know I don't know maybe a feature maybe
a uh Series yeah it'll be interesting to
see what happens after people after the
short comes out you know and uh what
people think and say etc etc um but
Daniel you actually never answered my
question if someone wanted to train to
be in action like what's the what how
long would it take to turn me into being
able to do action in a movie or a TV
show and like I said is there do people
have to have some sort of natural
ability or you can make anyone look good
with enough time so here's the thing
that that' be actually really fun thing
to do and maybe we should do that one
day with you oh no come on so
you have the whole team we'll do a
little scene you and together how fun
would that be so I'm want the cameras to
be damaged and people to get hurt I am
your guy now you're you're you're gonna
be great so like I said earlier it's
really depending on your natural talent
I could make we could make you the whole
team in one session we could shoot a
little fight scene and make you look
good now I swear to God and we could
test that and it's depending on your
talent and you know why I know that when
we did when we did promotion for nobody
we we invited all the reporters and they
came into 8071 we trained them for two
hours and at the end they did the fights
and look how well they did and it's all
depending on you I have an amazing we
have an amazing team here depending on
how you are we go a little tighter we go
a little wider we go a little bit to the
side this is our job you have the best
people in the world here to make you
look good we could make you look good in
one session my friend sure I I did a
thing for Jurassic World in Malta where
they we did an action thing and um and
they they did a lot of close-ups I'll
just say it like that I'm joking I tell
you with us with us I tell you right now
we'll be here
right sure and that's the other thing
Stephen is they these guys make me look
good you know what I mean like Sean Fong
and Daniel and the way they take the
hits the way they move they make me look
and they protect me it's their first job
is to protect the
bleed you know and make sure when you
make a mistake me that they're there to
see it and catch it before anybody gets
hurt and so uh it's just an amazing
group of people I love these guys so
much and all the people who work in this
community and so one of the fun things
about talking to you and sharing this on
collider was to share this group of
people and the vibe of working with with
these great people I just want to ask
you during the this is not going to
spoil anything but during the credits
you have the blooper reel and um you get
to see uh Bob saying me a lot
because of making a mistake so a how
much did you debate putting the blooper
reel in this and and what was it like
because Bob this was your first time
doing stuff on camera like this so talk
a little bit about you know doing it on
camera and you know what I mean like and
anyway yeah look I we never thought this
would be released I mean we did this for
ourselves I mean John wanted to direct
something everybody who contributed and
John I don't know who made the music I
don't know who did that title sequence
that's so great these everyone
contributed um so so we did not look I
just wanted the pressure of the crew the
time limitations and you know to deliver
it and to see it on camera and to do
this once before I got on on my first
feature so that's all I was asking for
and I didn't care if it cut together
perfectly or you know John went and made
this beautiful fun thing that I am
extremely proud of and think is totally
topnotch uh but I did not expect
that so do you want to talk about uh the
blooper reel
oh the blooper reel well I mean I still
treated it like I treated better Cal if
you wanted if they just included every
time I said me the blue baral would
be hours
long but usually on better call Sol was
because I screwed up a line uh not
because I made a a mistaken move which
can be dangerous on a stunt set um uh
more than so it's it's even worse than
screwing up your
lines
um yeah I mean I had pressure I wanted
it to be great but I didn't expected to
be this
great and I'm glad the blooper real is
there because it's all in fun I mean
really this is this there's a fun Spirit
to this I'm glad we went as dark and
hard as we did in nobody that's what
that movie was meant to be from the
beginning but I would love a chance
to do fighting action like we did and
wish me luck with more of a fun Spirit
to it a lighter Spirit like I said uh
I'm very curious what's going to happen
after the short because you have the
proof of concept now that you can now
show people it's different when you talk
about it and you walk into a meeting and
say this is what I'm thinking now you
can just be like watch this eight
minutes and have me you know let's let's
talk yeah yeah sure well maybe it'll
help us but I will I'm I'm glad to share
this with people there are so many
people who are waiting for a nobody
Sequel and I know I want to do more in
the action space so I'm just thrilled to
share this with everybody also it's a
good it's a good vibe this piece my this
is going to probably be my last question
because you guys have been very generous
with your time but all of you who I'm
talking with all five of you have done
action now and I'm just curious if
someone has never seen an action scene
that you have been a part of what is the
first one you'd like them watching and
why you guys
go you
go you may have to ask that question one
more time everybody has to answer this
question name a scene that you're in
that you would an action scene that
you're in that you would love people
well that we in all so but it's like if
they've never seen anything you've done
this is the first you want them
watching wow I can only pick one one
yeah you can only pick one game I know
you've done about a thousand but it's
one don't don't pick the bus scene in
nobody because that's
mine all right I'll pick oh I know what
you're gonna pick what Atomic blonde I
was I was between atomic blonde and John
wig can I pick two if if you really want
to you can do two okay I'll pick two um
Atomic blonde the staircase fight is
insane I end up in the um in the Gypsy
room downstairs which is an insane fight
scene um and then John Wick of course
you know my favorite K Reeves fighting
him in the club that was amazing which
which one which John Wick John one first
one
yeah oh
la uh yeah there are a lot of Hollywood
movies that I worked on but there's one
very close to my heart which is called
Plan B which we did in Germany which was
released by 20th Century Fox and I would
say the final fight of Plan B final
fight
of guys it's the same it's Plan B it's
our feature film in Germany it's our
first film and um I was playing one of
the main actors there so I would say the
fight with um ID Money Maker in the
script club yeah a good one
Plan B for me it's actually plan B too
but I don't want to know just to promote
plan b or something El like in case I
have to choose another one it might be
uh Hopson Shan when I was fighting
against Jason oh that's cool yeah that
was a big scene which film is
that Hobson Shaw Hopson Shaw hops Shaw
which scene uh is it when um The Rock
and Jason were standing in front of like
two doors oh right the wholeway fight
fight yeah that was a or was like
getting sh the one exactly that was good
funny enough we were all on this movie
we were
all me and Daniel were fighting him in a
kitchen in the house and then these guys
were fighting him in the hallway so yeah
yeah that's how close we
are I Just Want to Thank You Stephen and
I want to thank kider for presenting our
little movie we're so proud of it we
love it so much and we can't wait to
share it with people